acht jahre so lange hat es vom ersten
menschen im weltall bis zur mondlandung
gedauert in den jahren danach gab es die
erste raumstation den ersten deutschen
astronauten die iss und letztes jahr
sogar den ersten milliardär immer und
jetzt naja knapp 53 jahre später haben
wir natürlich schon einige fortschritte
gemacht aber so einen krassen
meilenstein die 1969 haben wir irgendwie
nicht mehr erreicht finde ich zumindest
natürlich haben wir keine zauberkugel
die uns die zukunft vorhersagen kann
aber markiert euch doch schon mal im
kalender den 22 august
2033 denn dieser tag könnte in die
geschichtsbücher eingehen herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge doktor
watson
[Musik]
wo stehen wir eigentlich in elf jahren
optimistisch gesehen kommt dann die bahn
endlich mal pünktlich die
digitalisierung läuft wie am schnürchen
und die klimakrise ist abgewendet
pessimistisch gesehen geht alles noch
mehr den bach runter als es ohnehin
schon gerade der fall ist und na ja
realistisch ist irgendwo dazwischen und
genau darüber wollen wir heute reden
einen realistischen blick auf die
zukunft der bemannten raumfahrt klar die
bahnbrechenden tollkühnen aussichten
sind irgendwie die spannendsten aber
noch spannender werden zukunftsszenarien
in meinen augen wenn es auch irgendwie
realistisch ist dass sie tatsächlich
eintreten deswegen sind wir auf ein
datum gestoßen das super spannend ist
weil es vielleicht genau so kommen wird
also machen wir nägel mit köpfen der 22
august
2033 wird der tag an dem zum ersten mal
menschen auf dem mars landen werden
definitiv ganz sicher keine frage
hundertprozentig
natürlich nicht also natürlich aber
immer noch keine magische zauberkugel
aber dieses datum hört sich im gegensatz
zu vorherigen schätzungen relativ
realistisch an warum genau dieser tag
nun man hört ja schon seit ewigkeiten
dass wir bald auf dem mars landen werden
oder schauen uns noch mal genauer an
warum das bisher noch nicht geklappt hat
zum einen ist der mars natürlich
deutlich weiter entfernt als der mond
auch wenn man beide von der erde
aussehen kann weiter weg bedeutet in dem
fall dass aus ein paar reisetagen mal
eben ein paar reise monate werden ergo
es wird ganz schön teuer
warten wir also seit 53 jahren weil die
nasa solange das sparschwein film musste
naja nicht ganz aber doch schon
irgendwie der knackpunkt sind die
geldgeber denn die entscheiden wie viel
geld die nasa für ihr sparschwein jedes
jahr bekommt aber gehen wir erstmal noch
einen schritt zurück seit wann gibt es
denn eigentlich schon pläne zum mars zu
fliegen ob ihr es glaubt oder nicht
schon während der apollo er arbeitet man
innerhalb der nasa an konzepten für eine
bemannte mars-mission die dann der
apollo nachfolger werden sollte also
quasi vom mond zum mars hatte man das
kommt mir irgendwie bekannt vor zum mars
programm zum mars wird der nächste große
schritt der menschheitsgeschichte auf
dem mond landen desto schneller kommen
wir auch zum makel nach atem ist vom
mars genau diese idee vom mond zum mars
hat die trump regierung 2016 dann wieder
aufgewärmt und atem ist genannt und das
ist eigentlich auch gar nicht so typisch
verschiebung und neuausrichtung ist
sowas wie das inoffizielle motto der
nasa der ursprüngliche plan nach apollo
zum mars zu fliegen wurde aufgrund von
mehreren budgetkürzungen damals fallen
gelassen und auf unbestimmte zeit
verschoben dafür wollen wir aber gar
nicht direkt die nasa verantwortlich
machen der größte flucht der nasa ist
vermutlich dass jeder us präsident eine
neue idee hat wie man das budget am
besten verwendet aber moment mal sagt
ihre masse nicht schon seit jahren dass
die mars landung quasi kurz vor der tür
steht
2033 das ist doch erst in elf jahren
dass das schiff ist aber gefühl schon
fertig oder nicht ja ok fast aber sei es
drum wenn es nach ihrem us geht dann
handelt es sich nur noch um wenige jahre
und nicht um mehr als ein jahrzehnt bis
wir zum mars fliegen aber ist das auch
realistisch bisher wurden alle termine
von spacex verschoben ähnlich wie bei
der nasa die iss prototypen machen zwar
fortschritte aber ansatzweise bereit für
einen interplanetaren flug sind die noch
lange nicht das könnten sie aber schon
sein wenn ihre maske blinkt ist kennen
würde denn blinkt ist fast ganze bücher
in 15 minütige text und audio erklärer
zusammen damit kann man sich mega
schnell und trotzdem faktenbasiert in
ein thema einlesen wenn ich das thema
raumfahrt und die zukunft der menschheit
interessiert dann könnt ihr euch zum
beispiel the future of humanity von
michio kaku zusammenfassen und auch
vorlesen lassen er gilt als einer der
bekanntesten physiker der usa und
schreibt in seinem buch über die zukunft
der menschheit als raum fahrende
zivilisation mega spannend wie ich finde
und ihr könnt es auch downloaden
natürlich gibt es auch noch über 4.500
weitere sachbücher und podcasts aus den
bereichen physik ernährung persönliche
entwicklung technik und zukunft die gibt
es echte richtig viel zu entdecken und
falls sie immer noch nicht ganz
überzeugt seid ihr könnt komplett
kostenlos sieben tage lang alle
möglichen bücher auf blinkt es testen
und jederzeit kündigen also falls sie
dieses angebot gut findet dann könnt ihr
jetzt auf linke.de / doktor watson 25
prozent rabatt auf ein jahres abo blinkt
es premium bekommen und damit
unterstützt er auch noch zusätzlich
diesen kanal hier vielen dank klickt
einfach auf den ersten link unten in der
video beschreibung und fangen an zu
lernen und danke an blinkt ist für die
unterstützung bei diesem video hier und
jetzt geht es zurück ins jahr 2033 die
politischen entscheidungen rund um die
nasa habe ich ja bereits umrissen ohne
ein festes ziel und einen langfristigen
plan der nicht alle vier jahre von einem
neuen präsidenten umgeworfen wird dauert
es einfach ewig aber gut sagen wir mal
dass mit dem budget bekommt die nasa
schon irgendwie geregelt dann stehen wir
immer noch vor anderen problemen der
mars ist ja wie bereits erklärt sehr
weit weg astronauten müssen über mehrere
monate im raumschiff überleben bis sie
am planeten ankommen es müssen extra für
den flug technologien entwickelt werden
die die crew vor der hohen kosmischen
strahlung schützen und verhindern dass
ihre körper ohne gravitation zu stark
verfallen und das nur damit sie ihre
mission auf dem mars überhaupt erst
antreten können selbst wenn man
technisch in der lage dazu wäre müssen
wir ja dann auch noch irgendwie die zwei
jahre auf dem roten planeten überleben
bis erde und mars wieder so gut
zueinander in position stehen dass eine
rückreise überhaupt möglich wird die
sicherheit der crew hat natürlich
oberste priorität ist aber eben auch
ganz schön teuer was die planung
verkompliziert
aber was wenn es ein zeitfenster geben
würde an dem sich die dauer des fluges
und damit auch die kosten der aufwand
und das risiko mehr als halbieren maß
flüge im 50 prozent sonderrabatt quasi
genau dieses fenster öffnet sich alle 15
jahre und das nächste ist vom
dreißigsten april bis zum 22 august 2033
dann stehen die planeten so perfekt in
ihren umlaufbahnen dass ein highspeed
transfermöglichkeit in der praxis heißt
das dass man nicht mal 114 tagen also
vier monaten beim roten planeten ankommt
denn um von der erde zum mars zu fliegen
ist das zeitfenster entscheidend oft ist
ja die rede von einem flug alle 26
monaten dastehen mars und erde dann so
dass ein flug nur bis zu neun monate
dauert das zeitfenster alle 15 jahre ist
also besonders wertvoll und sowohl space
ex als auch die nasa werden alles in
bewegung setzen um es zu nutzen ja geil
dann sind wir schon in elf jahren auf
dem mars nun ja spacex ist hier aktuell
unsere einzige wirklich realistische
hoffnung ursprünglich war aber auch
jeder plan bei 2.024 menschen auf den
mars zu landen spacex planten aber doch
erstmal 2026 und ihre maske selber
twittert inzwischen schon von 2029
korrigiert also immer weiter nach hinten
spätestens bis zur nächsten mondlandung
muss zumindest eine erste version des
schiffs fertig sein die eine kleine crew
auf dem mond landen kann denn dafür
wurde space ex von der nasa beauftragt
das ganze wird nicht vor 2025 passieren
stand heute schafft die firma das dann
kann es natürlich sein dass maske 2029
schon ready für einen ersten flug zum
mars ist aber ob da auch menschen mit
fliegen werden halte ich persönlich für
fraglich 2033 kann er dann richtig ernst
machen und eine ganze flotte an starship
es zum halben preis auf den roten
planeten loslassen aber das ist wirklich
der der sechser im lotto und dafür muss
wirklich alles glatt gehen und für die
nasa sieht es leider noch mal ein stück
schlechter aus denn es gibt auch stimmen
in der wissenschaft die selbst 2033 noch
als unrealistisch einschätzen professor
doktor ulrich walter ist einer davon er
arbeitet als diplom physiker an der
technischen universität münchen er ist
astronaut und schrieb über die erste
bemannte mars-mission sogar in einem
seiner bücher professor doktor walter
hat sich das datum zweiter august 2008
rund 40 dick in seinem kalender
angestrichen also ein 15 jahres zyklus
später er glaubt nicht daran dass die
nasa 2033 schon genug budget hat
geschweige denn die technologien dafür
weit genug entwickelt sind im ersten
moment mögen sich elf jahre nach richtig
viel zeit anhören aber sie sind es
eigentlich nicht wie gesagt wir wollten
in diesem video hier realistisch sein
aktuell hält die administration von
präsident biden am atomprogramm fest die
nasa wird also erstmal mit der hilfe von
spacex und eventuell noch weiteren
firmen zum mond fliegen und dort eine
forschungsbasis errichten hier gibt man
dann für eine spätere mars-mission und
lebenswichtige technologien wie zum
beispiel die herstellung von sauerstoff
und treibstoff auf einem anderen
planeten werden erst mal auf die probe
gestellt eine groß angelegte studie die
die us regierung in auftrag gegeben hat
sollte herausfinden ob eine mars landung
2033 theoretisch möglich sein das
ergebnis der studie das klappt nicht um
mast 2033 nicht komplett abschreiben zu
müssen wurde dann die neue mondlandung
von 2028 auf 2024 vorgezogen aber selbst
2024 ist nach aktueller einschätzung der
nasa selbst sehr unrealistisch da sich
mal wieder alles verschoben hat und
damit rückt dann auch mars 2033 für die
nasa wieder in weite ferne
das heißt also der 22 august 2033 ist
vermutlich unsere erste große chance
astronauten zum mars zu befördern der
highspeed transport halbiert die kosten
und die reise ist mit 114 tagen
vergleichsweise extrem kurz erst 15
jahre später bekommen wir noch mal so
eine chance falls ihr 2033 also
verpassen dann liegt 2048 wirklich weit
genug in der zukunft um alles nötige für
die marsmission zu erforschen und bereit
zu machen wir können die erkenntnisse
vom mond ganz in ruhe auswerten und dort
dann anwenden natürlich wäre es traurig
wenn wir noch 15 weitere jahre warten
müssten aber es gibt ja noch space exile
mast wiederum die großen versprechen von
einer mars landung in diesem jahrzehnt
einlösen kann das bleibt abzuwarten
genau wie die nasa hat auch ihre maske
eine gewisse tendenz dazu selbst
gesteckte deadlines nicht einzuhalten
wann also 1 tasche oder sogar mehrere
starts gleichzeitig 100 menschen jeweils
zum mars fliegen das steht noch in den
sternen aber schreibt mir doch gerne mal
eure vorhersagen unten in die kommentare
wann wird der erste mensch den mars
betreten falls sie uns unterstützen
wollt und videos wie dieses hier vor
allen anderen sehen wollt dann schaut
doch mal unsere pajun seite unten in der
video beschreibung aus und ansonsten
danke fürs zuschauen und bleibt
neugierig